...
-Corinne Herrmann,
comment devient-on Mme "Cold cases",
Mme "Affaires non résolues",
en VF ?
-Un peu par hasard.
Un peu par hasard.
J'avais pas prévu
de faire ce métier.
-C'est même un métier
qui est venu par effraction,
un peu,
non ?
-Oui, on m'a forcé la main.
Le sort, la destinée,
m'a forcé un peu la main.
-Au départ,
c'était un boulot temporaire,
mais ça vous a happée.
-J'avais étudié le droit,
j'avais un bac +5 en droit,
c'est pas la question,
j'avais la base juridique.
Je suis rentrée dans un cabinet
d'avocats par hasard,
j'aimais pas beaucoup
ce que faisaient les avocats.
-Pourquoi ?
-Je trouvais que ces personnes
la ramenaient,
avaient toujours
quelque chose à dire sur tout.
Et puis, je trouvais que défendre
des criminels posait problème,
je savais
que je pouvais pas le faire,
j'avais envie...
J'étais jeune,
mais j'aurais plutôt envie
de leur dire leurs quatre vérités.
Je m'étais pas préparée à faire
ce métier.
Parler en public est quelque chose
qui m'est difficile,
contrairement
à ce qu'on pourrait penser.
Plaider était quelque chose
qui était
contre ma nature.
Je suis rentrée
dans un cabinet d'avocats
le temps de trouver
un travail différent.
-Et ?
-J'en suis pas ressortie.
Comme quoi, le provisoire dure.
-Le provisoire,
c'est que vous êtes devenue
en 27 ans
la cousine française
de Lillian Rush,
l'héroïne de la série "Cold Case",
aux côtés de Me Seban.
L'ironie de l'histoire,
c'est que vous avez commencé
par être du côté de la défense
des tueurs avant de les traquer.
Et l'un de vos tout premiers clients
a été Francis Heaulme, le routard
du crime.
-C'est vrai que dans le cabinet
où je suis entrée,
celui de mon oncle,
Pierre Gonzalez de Gaspard,
il avait deux tueurs en série
en magasin.
Il avait Pierre Chanal,
celui qu'on suppose être l'auteur
des disparitions à Mourmelon,
et puis, il y avait Francis Heaulme,
qui occupait beaucoup le cabinet.
Il y avait plusieurs instructions
en cours,
il était en reconstitution,
en cour d'assises.
Ca m'a permis de voir ce métier,
de voir le pénal de l'intérieur.
Petit à petit, je suis rentrée
dans la défense de Francis Heaulme
et j'ai beaucoup appris
de cette défense, mais j'étais pas
à ma place.
-Il vous a fait toucher du doigt
ce que pouvait être un prédateur,
il vous a donné envie
de creuser le sujet, Heaulme ?
-Oui, on rencontrait
peu de tueurs en série,
c'était pas la mode,
il n'y avait aucun livre
qui en parlait,
on les cherchait à l'étranger.
-Aux Etats-Unis ?
-Aux Etats-Unis,
en Afrique du Sud, en Autriche.
Il y avait de bons profilers.
Je suis allée suivre des formations,
chercher des informations
pour savoir
quel était ce phénomène
de cet homme
qui avait tué une dizaine de fois
et peut-être plus,
certains disaient une cinquantaine.
Beaucoup se moquaient de lui,
de ses attitudes,
il était particulier, néanmoins,
je sentais que si j'étais seule
avec lui, j'avais aucune chance.
C'est comme rentrer
dans la cage d'un lion
sans être dresseur,
sans avoir de fouet.
Je ressentais cette dangerosité.
Quand je suis entrée
dans l'équipe de défense,
il était dans notre dos,
je la ressentais à chaque minute.
Je demandais à ce qu'il y ait
des policiers
dans la cour d'assises,
mais pas autour,
vraiment au coeur
de la cour d'assises.
On avait décidé de le faire
à chaque fois, parce qu'il restait
dangereux, même dans un box.
-L'affaire qui vous fera basculer
du côté des victimes,
c'est celle des disparues
de l'Yonne datant des années 70,
aux yeux du parquet une affaire
classée, enterrée.
-A la fois, c'était une affaire
classée pour le parquet
et on nous disait
qu'il n'y avait pas de dossier.
C'est évidemment très intéressant,
intellectuellement,
c'est intéressant de décrypter
les courriers du parquet disant :
"Il n'y a pas de dossier.
"Nous n'avons pas de procédure,
mais on l'a classée."
-Comment avez-vous remis en haut
de la pile ce non-dossier ?
-C'est mon premier dossier pénal,
ma première plainte pénale.
Je mets trois mois à la rédiger,
c'est pas efficace.
C'est dix plaintes pénales
qui vont dans le même sens,
avec sept familles différentes.
Il fallait que tout converge
pour qu'on aille vers Emile Louis,
qu'on puisse avoir une plainte
qu'il était
le dernier à les avoir vues.
Le fait d'avoir
sept familles,
c'était déjà une façon
de construire le dossier,
de montrer son importante.
Et puis ensuite,
c'est Pierre Monnoir, qui était
président de l'association.
Notre binôme a fonctionné
autour de la plainte et la presse.
L'affaire des disparues de l'Yonne
n'existe pas sans Pierre Monnoir
et sans mon travail,
mais l'affaire existe parce que
la presse va s'y intéresser
et empêcher la justice
de revenir en arrière.
-Finalement, sans votre obstination,
Corinne Herrmann,
Emile Louis aurait coulé
une retraite heureuse
pendant des années.
Vous l'avez fait tomber.
-Vous êtes gentille de me le dire.
Je ne le revendique pas toute seule,
mais c'est vrai qu'Emile Louis,
ça a été...
Emile Louis, ça a fonctionné
parce que ça a été
des heures et des heures
de travail, d'analyses.
Mes parents me rappelaient
que dans mon appartement,
les photos étaient au sol
avec des dossiers, des convergences.
Ca a été un travail...
On ne se rend pas compte
du travail qu'on a effectué
derrière ce dossier
et de la relation
avec Pierre Monnoir
qui portait la parole
pendant que j'étais dans l'ombre
à travailler les dossiers.
-Peut-on dire que c'est grâce à vous
que la France
a découvert l'existence
de tueurs en série
en France ?
La France a longtemps été
dans le déni.
Chez nous, ça n'existe pas.
Ca existe aux Etats-Unis,
mais pas en France.
-C'est vrai
qu'à l'époque, on entendait :
"Il n'y a pas de tueurs en série."
Et devant le nombre de tueurs
en série identifiés :
"Ce ne sont pas les mêmes
qu'aux Etats-Unis."
Evidemment, ils répondent
à une société spécifique.
Ensuite, ça n'a plus tenu.
J'allais encore
à des conférences
dans les années 2000-2005
où des pseudo-spécialistes niaient
l'existence des tueurs en série
alors qu'il y en avait en prison.
Je les ai pas révélés,
ça a été une période
entre 95 et 2000 où on arrêtait
successivement des tueurs en série.
Il y a eu Guy Georges, Alègre,
Francis Heaulme qui était identifié
comme un tueur en série.
Il y en a eu d'autres.
Ces tueurs ont fait
que la justice...
Je croyais que la justice
avait pris conscience.
La presse avait pris conscience
qu'on en avait.
-Vous "croyiez" ?
-La justice a mis longtemps
à accepter
qu'on avait des tueurs en série.
On parlait de criminels
multirécidivistes.
C'était chaque fois un phénomène
exceptionnel, rare.
C'est faux.
Il a fallu la création
de ce pôle cold cases...
-Pôle spécialisé dans ces affaires ?
-Spécialisé dans les affaires
en sérialité de tueurs en série.
-Ca, c'est une avancée majeure.
-Oui.
C'est un gros mot
dans le Code, aujourd'hui.
On ne prononçait pas ce mot.
C'est la reconnaissance
que ces tueurs existent.
On est loin de savoir les traiter,
on a perdu l'expérience
qu'on avait en 90-2000,
on a perdu sur le terrain.
-Dans les années 80,
on était à la traîne.
Il y avait 1 policier scientifique
pour 60 en Allemagne.
Cette discipline est restée
de la SF, elle était à la traîne.
-Alors, on est toujours à la traîne.
-Aujourd'hui ?
-Ca ne plaira pas,
mais on est à la traîne.
On doit se saisir de la création
de ce pôle spécialisé
pour pouvoir remettre les choses
en ordre, travailler les dossiers,
rechercher ces criminels en série
qui restent actifs.
Tout cela vient aussi
de ce que les vieux dossiers
ou en tout cas les dossiers
criminels étaient abandonnés
très vite
par nos juges d'instruction.
Quand on abandonne un dossier
au bout de 2 ou 3 ans,
on laisse le criminel dehors
et il peut récidiver.
Je dis que nous les créons.
Nous avons une éclipse judiciaire
entre les années 2000-2005
et aujourd'hui qui fait
qu'on a parlé de peu de tueurs
en série depuis 20 ans
alors qu'il sont là.
-Vous avez une estimation du nombre
de tueurs en série en circulation ?
-Je n'en ai pas.
Mais on pourra avoir une estimation
des séries criminelles
lorsqu'on aura établi un fichier
des affaires non résolues.
-Ca n'existe pas ?
-Ce fichier n'existe pas en France.
-Vous avez un ordre d'idée ?
-J'ai...
En tout cas, moi,
je suis depuis 15 à 20 ans
une quinzaine de séries en France.
Je ne comprends pas
qu'elles ne soient pas
retravaillées,
ce sont des séries anciennes
des années 90.
Il y en a de plus récentes.
J'espère que tout cela sortira.
-Comment vous expliquez
que ces enquêtes soient bâclées ?
Un manque de moyens ?
-Elles ne sont pas bâclées,
elles ne sont pas menées.
-Pourquoi ?
-Je ne sais pas répondre
à cette question.
C'est d'abord des dysfonctionnements
internes à notre système,
c'est un manque d'envie,
c'est un manque de formation,
de connaissances.
Ca n'est pas le complot,
comme on veut le penser
ou comme on le voit
sur les sites.
C'est des magistrats
qui n'ont pas le temps,
qui n'ont pas envie
de reprendre des dossiers,
qui ne connaissent pas
les techniques.
On a malheureusement,
je le constate,
des magistrats qui ne connaissent
pas la criminalistique,
la police scientifique.
Quand on fait des demandes,
on doit expliquer aux magistrats
qu'on peut utiliser telle technique.
Ils ne connaissent pas
la criminologie,
la notion de l'acte criminel,
la notion du comportement du tueur
et a fortiori du tueur en série.
On a beaucoup de retard
sur la formation des magistrats,
et ils n'en ont pas envie.
Leur cabinet déborde de dossiers,
il faut traiter en priorité
les détenus,
car on a des risques
de libération.
Et puis,
se plonger dans un dossier
qui fait 10, 15, 20 tomes...
Soit on en trouve pas le temps,
soit on en a pas envie.
Avant tout le reste,
on a un système défaillant.
On a le parquet
qui ne poursuit pas,
qui ne stimule pas les magistrats.
Le juge d'instruction
n'a pas envie de le faire,
ne le fait pas et se dit :
"Je vais être là 3 ans,
je le refilerai..."
-J'imagine
que votre rôle d'avocat
est primordial
pour réveiller
et rouvrir ces dossiers.
-C'est vraiment notre travail.
On essaye de restimuler ce système.
Je m'y épuise depuis 27 ans.
C'est pour ça que je voulais
la création d'un pôle spécifique
où on aurait des magistrats
qui restent longtemps,
qui ont les techniques,
qui vont se spécialiser,
comme le pôle antiterrorisme
et qui auront envie de le faire.
-Vous êtes d'accord
avec l'ancien procureur de Reims
que notre institution judiciaire
ne peut pas gérer un meurtrier
du calibre de Fourniret ?
"Elle est pensée
pour les crimes de proximité."
Vous partagez ce constat ?
-Non.
Il a eu l'occasion
de changer les choses,
puisqu'il a traité
le dossier Fourniret,
le volet français et le volet belge,
que les Belges nous avaient confié.
Ils ont eu l'occasion
d'apprendre de Fourniret,
de Michel Fourniret.
Ils ont tous participé
à la fermeture
du dossier Fourniret
après le procès de 2008,
ce qui nous amène aux difficultés
qu'on a dans les dossiers
Estelle et autres.
Il y a eu un rapport
qui a été fait à l'époque,
qui a été demandé par le ministère
sur les tueurs en série,
qui n'a été suivi de rien,
mais absolument de rien,
car on a considéré
qu'on avait peu de tueurs en série,
que c'était un épiphénomène
et qu'il n'y avait pas lieu
de dépenser des moyens.
-Vous êtes allée jusqu'à organiser
des manifestations
sur les fenêtres des palais
de justice pour que les magistrats
consentent à rouvrir des dossiers.
La méthode sit-in, ça marche ?
-Je l'ai peu fait,
c'est nos clients
qui nous demandent.
On a dit récemment que nos clients
voulaient s'enchaîner au tribunal.
Des associations de victimes
le font avec des victimes.
Moi, je les lâche pas
dans ces démarches.
-Est-ce que ça marche ?
-Alors...
Oui, parce que la presse
s'y intéresse.
Un tribunal n'a pas envie
qu'on donne cette image de lui
et les magistrats, encore moins.
-Vous dites
qu'il y a une justice de classe.
-Ah oui, il y a
une justice de classe.
Il n'y a donc que la manifestation
qui peut être utile.
Mais il y a d'autres façons
de se comporter
qui peuvent
être très efficaces.
-Lesquelles ?
-Je peux me mettre en colère
devant un magistrat.
Le plus dur pour les victimes
sont les fausses promesses
que l'on relaie.
On fait parfois attendre
nos clients des années.
Mais la manifestation,
c'est une façon
de dire les choses
pour que les autres entendent,
pour que les autres usagers
entendent.
C'est pas très bien vécu, en France,
c'est pas toujours très bien suivi.
C'est mieux d'avoir
la presse avec nous.
La manifestation amène une presse
qui fait pression
sur les magistrats
et les politiques.
-Vous aviez coutume
d'arpenter par tous les temps
les scènes de crime.
Elles ont toujours
quelque chose à nous dire,
même des années après,
ces scènes de crime ?
-Oui.
Il faut retourner
sur les scènes de crime.
-On voit le château de...
-Ce château est glaçant.
-Dans les Ardennes.
-C'est un endroit très particulier,
en lui-même.
Il y a une...
Il y a une atmosphère,
avec ces grands arbres.
C'est très sombre, c'est très...
C'est une atmosphère particulière.
J'y suis retournée...
-Le château de l'Ogre.
-Oui.
Il y a plus de 20 ans.
Mais...
-Vous en avez encore des frissons ?
-Non, c'est...
C'est comme si...
Quelque part, ça vous pénètre.
La noirceur vous pénètre
quand même par moments.
C'est un des rares endroits
où elle vous pénètre vraiment.
D'abord, on y a trouvé
le corps de deux victimes.
Sur la victime
que nous représentions,
à l'époque, il roulait chaque jour
ou quasiment sur son corps.
Elle était à l'entrée de cette allée
qui fait presque 500 mètres.
Et puis, il y avait
une toute petite fille
de 8-9 ans
qui a été enterrée
devant sa cuisine,
dans une bâtisse
qui est sur le côté.
Il y a une empreinte particulière
dans ce lieu,
parce que Michel Fourniret,
comme Emile Louis,
ont eu un château.
Et donc, comme ce sont...
Ils étaient issus
d'une famille pauvre,
souvent avec des problèmes
qui étaient liés à la guerre,
avec des femmes qui ont été tondues
après la guerre,
une atmosphère de vie
très marquante.
La mère de Fourniret
servait dans un château,
pas celui-là,
un autre pas très loin.
Emile Louis
était adopté,
il était placé dans une famille,
il venait...
Il n'était rien,
il aspirait à être quelque chose,
c'est typique des tueurs en série.
Tous deux, dans leur château...
Quand on voit ce château,
on comprend le fonctionnement
de Michel Fourniret.
-De toute-puissance ?
-De toute-puissance...
La relation au pouvoir.
La toute-puissance,
on pourrait penser,
c'est pas tout à fait pareil,
mais l'importance qu'il avait pris
dans la société autour de lui.
-Encore une fois,
les scènes de crime ont toujours
quelque chose à nous dire ?
-Elles nous apprennent
quelque chose,
soit sur le comportement du tueur,
soit sur les difficultés
qu'il a rencontrées,
on peut alors les interroger,
soit sur quelle était leur vie
à ce moment-là,
leur état d'esprit,
et comment ils fonctionnaient.
Quand je suis allée
au château d'Emile Louis...
Depuis, je vais
sur les scènes de crime.
J'ai tout compris
à son fonctionnement.
J'ai élaboré toutes les questions...
-En fonction de vos constatations.
-Oui.
En fait, c'était un château
un peu différent de celui-là,
mais les propriétaires
n'y étaient jamais,
ou très peu,
donc il bénéficiait
de tous les bâtiments
de ce château.
Il jouait le châtelain
avec les petites jeunes filles
handicapées mentales,
cette puissance,
le fait de les emmener
dans un lieu magnifique,
elles vivaient dans des foyers,
il faut partir de là
pour comprendre.
C'est une façon de comprendre
comment ça s'est passé,
les difficultés qu'ils ont eues,
qu'ils ont rencontrées,
le temps qu'ils passent
sur les lieux avec une victime.
Ca change toute la façon
d'appréhender l'acte criminel,
les difficultés du criminel,
comment il fonctionne.
-En 2021,
Fourniret a emporté
ses secrets dans la tombe.
Comment vous vivez cela ?
-A titre personnel, très mal.
-Vous vous êtes battue
pendant 15 ans
pour que son nom soit relié
au meurtre d'Estelle Mouzin.
-Je le vis mal à titre personnel,
parce que j'aurais aimé
qu'on nous entende plus tôt.
Là, pour le coup, on a déployé...
On a travaillé, j'ai travaillé
des week-ends, des nuits,
pour convaincre les clients
de former appel
aux mauvaises décisions.
Il y a trois affaires
qui ont été condamnées,
les affaires Joanna Parrish,
Marie-Angèle Domece
et Estelle Mouzin.
-Estelle, que l'on voit.
-Oui, Estelle.
J'ai vécu avec cette photo...
presque depuis l'origine,
on a été saisis en 2006.
C'est un échec pour tout le monde,
c'est un échec pour nous,
parce que...
Il est parti avec ses secrets.
Des victimes
n'auront pas de réponse.
Mais surtout, on avait le temps
de le faire et la justice
l'a abandonné pendant 10 ans,
puisqu'on nous dit :
"Notre système sait pas faire."
Mais quand on ne fait pas
d'instruction,
quand on ne cherche pas,
évidemment qu'on va à l'échec
devant un tueur en série.
Les affaires Parrish
et Marie-Angèle Domece,
la femme de Fourniret
les avait avouées.
On nous a dit :
"Elle nous manipule."
Mais les premiers aveux
n'ont jamais été remis en cause.
Et puis, lui a fini par écrire
un courrier pour s'accuser.
Un criminel en série qui s'accuse,
ça demande des vérifications.
Pourquoi tout a été arrêté ?
Il a fallu qu'on se batte vraiment,
j'y ai passé du temps,
pour qu'on rouvre
le dossier Parrish,
et les autres ont suivi.
Mais ces dix ans de vide,
c'est incompréhensible
que dans une période
de justice moderne,
on n'ait pas continué à travailler.
C'est pas la mort de Fourniret
que je vis mal,
mais le fait qu'on ait perdu
tellement, tellement de temps
qu'aujourd'hui,
on n'a pas les corps d'Estelle,
de Marie-Angèle
et peut-être d'autres victimes.
-Votre petite soeur
a été enlevée quand vous aviez
14 ans et qu'elle était
sous votre surveillance.
Difficile de ne pas voir un lien
entre cet événement
et votre vocation.
-Chacun analysera comme il l'entend.
-Comment vous l'analysez ?
-J'en ai parlé et depuis,
j'ai eu des agressions,
des mails agressifs là-dessus.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-Des gens qui se servent
de ce que vous dites dans les médias
pour essayer, par malveillance,
de faire du mal.
C'est pour ça que je ne voulais pas
être avocate.
Donc, est-ce que c'est ce qui fait
qui m'anime aujourd'hui ?
Il est certain
que ce que moi et ma famille
avons vécu avec ma soeur
a fait que j'ai une façon
d'écouter et de rassurer
les victimes qui est différente,
on parle un langage commun.
Que ce soit un enlèvement
de quelques heures
ou un enlèvement
où on ne retrouve pas la personne,
la marque reste en vous.
Une famille, quelles que soient
les violences que vous vivez,
une famille reste marquée
par de telles violences.
Ca s'est bien fini,
on a retrouvé ma soeur, néanmoins,
les traces de ce qui s'est passé
restent aujourd'hui,
restent dans notre famille...
Une souffrance qui reste,
qui n'est pas celle
que peut ressentir la famille
d'Estelle Mouzin
ou des disparus de l'Isère.
Moi, ça m'a plutôt éloignée
de l'envie d'être avocate.
Je n'ai jamais eu envie de l'être,
plus magistrat ou policier,
mais ça m'a plutôt éloignée de ça.
C'est peut-être
un outil de compréhension,
mais je n'y pense pas
quand je travaille.
-Après 22 ans à traîner vos guêtres
dans les salles d'audience,
quel est le face-à-face
qui vous a le plus marquée ?
-Le plus fort,
c'est Monique Olivier.
-La femme de Michel Fourniret.
-Qui est pour moi une tueuse
en série au même titre que lui.
C'est...
Je n'ai pas les mots,
mais c'est Monique Olivier,
parce qu'elle nous ramène d'abord
à des actes commis par une femme
qui sont difficiles à supporter
pour d'autres femmes.
Elle est quand même celle
qui a armé Michel Fourniret,
qui lui a permis
de commettre des crimes,
parce que sans elle,
il était démuni, pas très doué.
Et puis,
elle est impressionnante
dans sa façon d'être
et d'écarter les émotions
concernant les victimes.
Elle est difficile à interroger.
C'est intéressant à faire
pour un avocat de la partie civile
quand on est face à elle,
parce qu'on a des échanges humains.
C'est très troublant,
ces échanges humains naturels
de femmes
où on va parler de coiffure,
de maquillage, de sa vie en prison,
et où tout d'un coup,
on va parler d'une fillette
qu'elle a accompagnée à la mort,
qu'elle aurait pu libérer.
C'est vraiment, pour moi,
peut-être, la criminelle
ou le criminel la plus...
qui est la plus impressionnante.
-Elle incarne pour vous
le mal absolu ?
-Monique Olivier
est le mal absolu, véritablement.
Elle aurait pu interrompre
quand elle voulait
la progression de Fourniret
et qu'elle y a trouvé son plaisir,
sans aucun doute.
C'est le mal absolu.
-Vous avez longtemps assimilé
voter travail à un bras de fer
avec la justice.
C'est encore le cas ?
-Le bras de fer avec la justice,
c'est le cas chaque jour,
y compris pour que des dossiers
soient confiés au pôle spécialisé
à Nanterre des cold cases,
c'est la souffrance des familles,
la façon dont elles sont niées
par la justice,
c'est toujours la même chose.
Je le supporte
encore moins aujourd'hui.
Je commence à plus du tout supporter
qu'un magistrat méprise
comme ça des familles.
On a une justice de classe
qui est encore plus importante,
le fossé est encore plus grand.
Cette justice imprime
et impose aux familles
de telles violences que parfois,
leur souffrance est plus due
à ce comportement
d'une justice attendue,
qui aurait dû les reconnaître
et les entendre,
que peut-être à l'acte principal.
C'est une double peine.
-Comment expliquez-vous ce mépris ?
Ce n'est pas à mettre sur le compte
des moyens dont ils disposent ?
Du manque de moyens ?
-La justice manque de moyens,
mais ça n'est pas la raison.
Quand on veut, on peut.
Quand les magistrats
et les enquêteurs ont envie,
on a aussi des difficultés
avec les enquêteurs,
quand ces deux forces-là
se réunissent et ont envie,
j'ai plus rien à faire.
Ca va très vite.
On résout une affaire très vite.
On a résolu une affaire
qui avait 36 ans en 5 mois.
-Au fond, vous me dites
qu'il n'y a pas d'affaire insoluble,
il y a des mauvais magistrats ?
-Il y a peu d'affaires qui résistent
à l'enquête, mais il faut enquêter.
-En 2014, Corinne Herrmann,
vous vous présentiez comme,
je vous cite,
"une éboueuse de la justice".
Vous diriez encore ça aujourd'hui ?
-Oui, je disais aussi
"la voiture-balai"...
Oui, toujours.
Très clairement, toujours.
-Les choses n'ont pas changé.
-Elles évoluent, enfin.
On les voit évoluer.
On les voit évoluer
depuis quelques années,
mais surtout depuis un an.
On a des magistrats ouverts
qui entendent
la voix des victimes
et la voix
de la nécessité de continuer
à travailler ces affaires.
Je sais que beaucoup d'avocats
sont choqués
par ce qu'on peut faire
côté victimes.
Dans ces affaires,
il y a eu des suspects qui,
pendant 30 ans, 35 ans, 20 ans,
sont restés les suspects
de leurs voisins,
de cette famille, qui sont restés
suspects dans leur famille
et qui ont besoin aussi
qu'on écarte cette suspicion d'eux.
Nous, on aime bien quand
ces personnes viennent nous dire :
"Je vais pouvoir vivre autrement.
"Même si on me croyait,
je sais qu'on me croyait pas.
"Cette suspicion était là."
Il faut pas oublier que donner
une réponse à une victime,
c'est aussi parfois protéger
des suspects de la justice
ou des suspects qui ont souffert.
Je dirais que je suis
une courroie de transmission,
aujourd'hui,
parce qu'on a eu des résultats,
parce qu'on a sorti des dossiers,
parce que j'ai dit
des choses qui se sont avérées
et bien analysées.
Il y a aussi des échecs,
mais ça nous aide aussi.
Je suis la courroie
de transmission.
Quand cette courroie
ne fonctionne pas,
on prend d'autres moyens.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...